évolution de la température sécheresse
dramatique après on sait toujours que
ces feux sont à 90% d'origine
anthropique
et donc il faut travailler là-dessus
alors sur ces 90% il y en a 20% c'est de
la malveillance donc là on les aura
toujours et puis le reste c'est de
l'accident
comment faire en sorte que ces accidents
arrivent de moins en moins donc pour ça
on s'est aperçu que il fallait informer
la population au maximum et les élus
entre autres parce qu'on a encore des
élus qui ont pas la conscience du feu et
donc ça veut dire que il faut prévoir
l'organisation et cette organisation
elle doit se faire aussi bien au niveau
interministériel de façon à ce qu'on est
plus l'opposition entre le code
forestier et le code de l'environnement
mais elle doit se faire aussi
sur tous les documents d'urbanisme sur
tous les documents de gestion de la
forêt parce que tout peut contribuer à
faire en sorte qu'on évite des feux
[Musique]
ces deux volets
s'ils sont ils ont le même poids pour
éviter les grandes feux ils ont pas du
tout le même poids économique
aujourd'hui 1 euro investi pour protéger
la forêt permet d'éviter 20 à 25 euros
quand il faut la défendre contre le feu
et donc une grosse partie de notre texte
a été justement de travailler sur la
partie de préparation de prévention
qu'aujourd'hui on oublie souvent et donc
notre idée ici c'était justement de
mettre en évidence tout ce qu'il faut
faire avant
une partie sur les Old les obligations
légales de débroussaillement et une
autre partie sur le rôle que peut jouer
les agriculteurs dans le la prévention
contre les incendies concernant les Old
on sait aujourd'hui que c'est le moyen
le plus sûr de protéger et les habitats
et les habitants contre le risque lié
aux incendies pourquoi parce que ça
consiste tout simplement à
débroussailler de la manière la plus
propre qui soit alors il y a des codes
il y a des normes pour correspondre
Roswell D et de permettre en cas
d'incendie très important de confiner
les personnes à l'intérieur de leur
habitat en sachant qu'elles seront
intégralement protégées or on s'aperçoit
que jusqu'à lors elles ne sont
pratiquées qu'à hauteur de 30%. donc on
a pris un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont été suivis en séance la première
étant de pour une meilleure information
quand il y a la transmission ou la vente
d'un bien immobilier obligatoirement il
est inscrit que c'est bien et soumis aux
old une franchise d'assurance dans
ne sont pas faites une pénalisation
beaucoup plus forte pour les personnes
qui déclareraient que leurs old sont
faites alors qu'elles ne sont pas faites
et un avoir fiscal un crédit d'impôt
pour les personnes qui réalisent le
relier de manière à les inciter
davantage à faire les olives et puis la
deuxième chose le deuxième point très
important qu'on a défendu c'est le le
rôle très important que peuvent avoir
les agriculteurs dans la prévention
contre les incendies à la fois sur leur
pratique agricoles mais aussi sur le
fait de créer des interfaces entre les
cultures et les forêts de manière que si
bien se développer un feu de végétation
au moment de la récolte notamment des
céréales ils ne puissent pas se
développer au niveau des forêts
[Musique]